Si on crée des connaissances et de l'expérience
on a besoin de les structurer.
Et la dernière chose est le soutien.
On a tous commencé novices.
Tout ce qu'on fait est une approximation de la sophistication.
On doit s'attendre à en changer au cours du temps. On doit encourager ça.
Le soutien peut venir en posant des questions à quelqu'un,
en lui montrant une feuille de papier avec un organigramme
ou quelques images directrices,
mais on a besoin de soutenir ça.
Le dernier point, le message clé
du point de vue de la mémoire de travail est ceci :
ce que nous traitons, nous l'apprenons.
Si on ne traite pas la vie, on ne la vit pas.
Vivez la vie. Merci.
(Applaudissements)